ihr denkt ihr habt schon alles über
dieses laurel yen ideen gehört ich denke
ich hatte noch was für euch für alle die
es verpasst haben die große debatte um
welche farbe hat das kleid weißgold
zurück in form einer audio-datei yeah
yeah yeah yeah
was hört ihr laurel oder juni stimmt
hier oben ab wie kann es sein dass
menschen zwei so unterschiedliche wörter
wie laurel und ja nie verstehen hier
drei wissenschaftliche erklärungen um 14
höheren höhere töne verschieden gut
diesen bennett ein game developer aus
portland hat dieses video mit der welt
geteilt wo er demonstriert dass die
tieferen tod frequenzen er noch lol und
die höheren er nachdenklich
steve point software ingenieur aus
boston hat fünf verschieden hoch
gepatchte version über twitter geteilt
je höher der pitch desto eher hört man
laut un in new york times hat ein
kleines leider tool erstellt wird man
selbst herausfinden kann ab wann man
laurel oder ja nie hört er besser höhere
frequenzen hören kann wird also eher
jährige das kann zum beispiel am alter
liegen die eltern die ohren desto
schlechter hören sie hören sie können
sie höhere hören sie hohe töne und zwei
tonhöhen sind subjektiv tonhöhen können
zweideutig wahrgenommen werden die musik
psychologen daniela deutsch hat das
anhand des so genannten streit von
paradox untersucht das machen wir jetzt
ja auch ich spiele euch jeweils zwei
töne vor und ihr seid mir ob die
tonfolge aufsteigend oder absteigend ist
das heißt ob der zweite ton höher oder
tiefer ist als der erste vier beispiele
bitte
[Musik]
so für mich war das jetzt gerade
aufwärts aufwärts abwärts aufwärts aber
ihr hört vielleicht etwas völlig anderes
in die kommentare wie kann das sein beim
tratschen paradox nimmt man immer zwei
töne die in einem abstand man sagt noch
intervall von einer halben oktave liegen
eine ganze oktave ist genau der selbe
ton nur höher oder tiefer zum beispiel c
eine reihe oktave entfernt vom c ist
fisch halb octavia ist der ton fis ist
von bayerns es gleich weit entfernt so
die töne die ich euch gerade vorgespielt
haben
sind bewusst so generiert dass unklar
ist auf welcher oktave sich die töne
befinden der ton entsteht durch eine
überlagerung und hat sowohl das von
diesem c als auch fast von diesem ziel
und je nachdem welche szeemann er
wahrnimmt ist das fis höher oder auch
tiefer ist das ziel dieses prinzip kann
man auf alle töne anwenden wenn man alle
halbtöne innerhalb einer oktave kreis
notiert dann kriegen wir eine art uhr
nachts weithin fängt der kreis wieder
von vorne an die flughafen stehen sich
nicht im kreis jeweils gegenüber und
jetzt kommt das eigentlich abgefahrener
diese empfindung der tonhöhe ist nicht
einfach rändern sondern bei jedem mensch
ist diese ton uhr anders rotiert weis s
en findet man die eine hälfte oder den
einen zusammenhängenden teil dieses
kreises immer höher als den rest nur bei
jedem menschen ist ein anderer teil um
darauf einfluss hat unter anderem die
eigene muttersprache und deren tonalität
selbst zwischen american english und
british english native speakern gab es
wesentliche unterschiede in der
wahrnehmung dieser trade in intervallen
das tri-team paradox ist ein sehr
spezieller fall und nicht direkt auf
jährige übertragbar aber es würde mich
nicht wundern wenn die abstimmungen
loriot es ist ja nie in verschiedenen
ländern sehr verschieden ausfallen
würden hinzu kommt dass entweder lokal
oder lenny in einer bestimmten sprache
vom klang her einfach vertrauter sein
könnte als das jeweils andere und was
uns vertrauter ist das beeinflusst uns
auch wer zum beispiel eine freundin
namens lorre hat wird wahrscheinlich
auch er lol höher und damit kommen wir
zur 3 wir hören was wir wollen unser
gehirn kann sich aussuchen was es hört
zum glück sonst hätte ich auch große
schwierigkeiten auf einer party wo sich
alle unterhalten mich auf mein gespräch
zu konzentrieren probieren wir das doch
mal ich erzähle euch jetzt was ihr könnt
mir zu hören
ihr könnt aber auch der zweite hinter
der kamera
augenthaler hat ich bin zwar akustisch
die bernsen verstehen streiks in seiner
also der lage ist auf dem zweiten sind
hier die immerhin eine beschreibung wäre
also zwei sachen gleichzeitig passieren
können wie oft unsere aufmerksamkeit auf
das ein oder andere bewusst link mit
blick auf die soundwave von sieht man
auch eine art überlagerung die aufnahme
enthält sowohl eigenschaften von laurel
als auch von jenen am anfang darf man
sogar bei dieser aufnahme handelt es
sich tatsächlich um eine überlagerung
beider wird entspricht und gibt es ein
paar wenige menschen die sowohl als auch
ja nie hören können wie nach dem auf was
sie sich konzentrieren könnt ihr das auf
schreibt in die kommentare was hören wir
aber gar nicht was wir hören wollen
sondern was wir hören sollen ihr schaut
mich an und sagt mir was ihr hört ba ba
ba ba ba ba richtig was hörte jetzt ba
ba ba ba fahrer richtig falsch jetzt
beide mal dasselbe gehört nämlich
barbara aber eure augen haben euch
gesagt dass ihr vater verhören sollte
was sie dann auch getan hat
nach dem was ihr seht hörte etwas
anderes das ist bekannt als der
sogenannte mega effekt und der hat viel
mit dem sogenannten priming zu tun
professor nina kraus vom auditorium
science lab von der northwestern hat
dazu ein beeindruckendes beispiel hört
euch das an
[Musik]
was höre dir geräusche rauschen
jedenfalls nichts bestimmt ist aber
jetzt hört euch mal folgendes an bremens
mixed und jetzt nochmal das erste
[Musik]
plötzlich hörte jetzt aus dem rauschen
dieses budgets of lemons und so weiter
raus
durch die zweite aufnahme wurden wie
dazu geplant auf genau diesen satz zu
achten hätte man jetzt dazu ich nur die
frage gestellt wer von euch hören
ohne jetzt die option laurel überhaupt
vorzugeben als prime hätte es gut sein
können dass vielen mehr leute in jene
gehörte allein die vorgabe der wörter
laurel und yen treibt uns also
beeinflusst uns ob wir es wollen oder
nicht übrigens was jetzt eigentlich die
richtige antwort er
sprachwissenschaftler professor brett
story hat die wetterlage und jedoch mein
sauber eingesprochen und kommt zu dem
schluss dass da ein gesprochen wurde ist
lol allerdings mit höheren stöhr
frequenzen die an das wort genie
erinnern ich höre auch neue aber falls
sie das nicht tut macht doch nix draus
ich habe es zum beispiel auch noch nicht
geschafft dieses blöde kleid in blau
schwarz zu sehen obwohl es das
eigentlich ist wir sehen uns nächsten
donnerstag freunde der sonne und in der
endart gibt es kekse
das internet ist so schnell freunde der
sonne inzwischen gibt es ja schon ein
neues level oder jene nämlich die ganze
brainstorm greet nieder geschichte warum
ist das so dass könnt ihr inzwischen
selbst erklären jura und virtuell jede
korrekte erklärung in den kommentaren
bekommt von mir persönlich ein keks
wir sehen uns bleibt sicher